SEASON.
IF THE KINGS GET EVERYTHING THE-
>> THE KINGS DID DROP BACK - MOM
AND THEN MAINTAIN CAPRISA.
IT'S A OR THE
NEW CROSS CHECK STANDARD IS
KINGS.
KEMPE, LOST IT IN HIS SKATES,
LOOKED LIKE
THE SEASON ON THEIR,
NOBODY THERE.
GAUDREAU GATHERS SIX SECONDS IN
THE PERIOD, GAUDREAU T T
AND TALBOTVES THEY CHIPPED THE
PUCK IN, STAYED ON TOP
A BIT OF A STAND STILL HERE. TOS
EXCITEMENT THESE ARE THE HANDS
OF A GOAL-SCORER. PUCK,
RASK OFF HIS STICK, MOVED A GRET
FIALA IS THE MOSO HEAR WHAT
STOLI AND ARMY HAVE HAVE TO PUC.
VILARDI SHIELDS FROM STURM.
KEMPE
KOPITAR TRIES TO MAKE ITTURNOVE.
PROTECT FIRST.
PROTECT AND
HED AWAY.
KEMPE.
TRIED TO TIP IT, IT WOUND UP
HAS HIS HAND DOWN.
AND THE PUCK LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ALREADY OVER THE LINE.
YES, IT IS, IT'S RIGHT HIS PAD
JAMMED AGAINST - - LOOK AT IT
NET. BECAUSE OF THE LEAVER
CENTERING PASS, FOLIGNO.
HARTMAN SCORES.
HARTMAN GOT THE BETTER OF
RIGHT NOW IN THIS PERIOD THE
WILDCERNING BUT AGAIN ONCE
THE KINGS SCORED THAT'S WHEN OFR
OF THE MINNESOTA WILD.
DOUGHTY STARTS THE RUSH.GETHER;
KINGS ARE WITHIN ONE.
>> I STEPPING UP.
THE KINGS TOP CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> 12.7